أنت أخيرًا مساء الخير لدينا واحدة
جودة هاتف ممتازة هناك
يضعنا على اتصال ، هذا جيد لأنه
لديك سؤال
باب على الهاتف
ما هو هذا السؤال بالضبط
ما رأيك هو علامة النداء
الولايات المتحدة رمز المنطقة ل
الولايات المتحدة
على مستوى الحكاية الشرقية الإرشادية
هذا ما تسألني عنه
السؤال لماذا نحن 1
حتى هنا أمريكا الشمالية وعضو
لما يسمى بخطة
ترقيم أمريكا الشمالية واسم في
اللغة الإنجليزية لذلك فهي غير المدخن
التي لا توجد نقاط مورينغ منذ أ
يعلق الاختصار أيضًا على كل هذا
هذا هو الرقم n إلى nbc هو نظام
من أرقام الهواتف التي في الواقع
كواحد إلى تسعة عشر دولة 19 دولة في
منطقة أمريكا الشمالية وهي في tnt
هل سمعت عنه من قبل
تي ان تي
كانت أول شركة كبيرة
هاتف في العالم
لذلك يبدو وكأنه برقية
نعم ، لقد انتظرنا حتى عام 1947 لإنشاء هذا
أضف 1 1 سمح للجميع
العالم لمشاركة خدمات معينة
مثل عندما يكون هناك ملف
طوارئ في الكاميرون
هل يوجد رقم هاتف
خاصة أنه يجب عليك تأليفها
شيء يعرفه الجميع
100 طيب وإذا كنت في gabon أنا
أظن أنه ليس 118 هو
ربما المعنى الذي حصلت عليه
لم يتم عمل شيء آخر ثم هذا
إنها مشكلة إنها مشكلة
هذا هو السبب في أمريكا الشمالية أو
في جميع أنحاء منطقة النفوذ
الأمريكية التي ندين بها على الإطلاق
الغوص كندا
اخترنا 1 مرفقًا بالرقم 1 هناك
كان لديه 9-1-1 خدمة الطوارئ
لذلك بغض النظر عن مكان وجودك
هذه المنطقة هناك مرة أخرى كان هناك
أي مشكلة على سبيل المثال أنا
أنا في إجازة في الشرق أبدا
أنا أؤلف القيام بذلك
وسأكون على اتصال مع
خدمات شرطة الإسعاف
رجال الاطفاء
نفس الشيء لـ 4-1 المشترك
هذه البلدان التسعة عشر هي للحصول على المساعدة
دليل أريد أن أعرف أ
رقم هاتف الشخص أو
6 1 1 مرة أخرى
هذا لخدمة الإصلاح
أو 7 1 1
هذا للأشخاص الذين
تسمع بشكل سيئ حتى يتم تشغيل هذه
منصة الهاتف هذه
نحن نتشارك نفس الهاتف وهو
شيء آخر عن الاتصالات الهاتفية
أمريكا الشمالية تريد أن تعرف
حول رموز المنطقة ربما كندا
لا ليس في التسعينيات
هكذا وليس طويلا وقليل
ما يقرب من عشرين عاما كنا
ملزمة باعتماد رقم إلى 10
الأرقام في المناطق الرئيسية
مدن كندا مما يعني
أننا بدأنا في ضرب الرقم
رمز المنطقة ، لدينا في
منطقة تورنتو
لقد أعدنا ترتيب رمز المنطقة 416 لدينا
أضيف في 905
هذا هو لضواحي تورنتو و
في عام 1998 أتذكر جيدًا
كان دور مونتريال للقيام به
الغرض من إعادة التنظيم هذه
كان لدينا 514 هناك أسميك واحدًا
رمز المنطقة 514 ولكن ذلك في
الضواحي نستخدم 450
في الآونة الأخيرة في الشرق في
أحدث الحالات التي أضفنا فيها
رموز المنطقة
المدن يجب أن تفكر في فانكوفر ، وهو
وجدت في كولومبيا البريطانية لديها
المجموعة المضافة 7 8 وهي تعمل من
يقترن بكود لبكي و 604
هل لديك واحد فقط في الكاميرون
دلالة لديك ربما اثنين
هل هو ما نناقشه
حقيقة أنه قد يكون من الضروري إضافة
يوم واحد إشارة النداء كنت لا تزال
بعيدا بما فيه الكفاية ثم تعرف
كيف تصل إلي
سأعطيك رقم هاتفي
هاتف المكتب في المرة القادمة
أنك تريد الانضمام إليّ حسنًا
1 هي إشارة نداءنا
اتفاق قاري متبوعًا بـ 5 1 4
هو رمز منطقتنا
ويتبعه رقم أعمالنا في
راديو كندا الذي هو 5 9 7 يتبع
متبوعًا دائمًا برقم التمديد الخاص بي
مباشرة إلى مكان جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بي
وكل شيء ما عدا الأدوات
إنه 7 5 8 9 7 8 9
ريك هنا ، نعم ، أكتب إليكم
دعنا نرى ما إذا كنت قد سمعتني بشكل صحيح
الاستماع اليك ما هو رقمي
هاتف
الرأس
هل أجبت بشكل صحيح
سؤالك الثيوفاني الرائع
لذلك لا تتردد في الاتصال بي
في المرة القادمة سؤال لطيف
مثل الذي يتبادر إلى الذهن
وطنية ما هو الراديو لذلك كان الأمر متروكًا له
دوالا في الكاميرون
ثيو فان مبوج ، المستمع البالغ من العمر 24 عامًا